hi guys I'm just going to do a quick
video to talk about the Star Trek Legacy
news I dropped a couple of days ago I
want to clarify a couple of things and
um explain it a little more maybe
welcome to SC SciFi TV I'm move a
[Music]
channel so I dropped the news a couple
of days ago that there is now an
agreement in place between Paramount
secret hideout and and um Amazon Prime
about how a new series of Legacy when
it's agreed when it's green lit when it
goes into development how it will be
paid for Paramount have significant
financial issues at the moment and what
I'm being told is before agreeing in
green lighting and moving ahead with
Star Trek Legacy they wanted to have an
an agreement with Amazon on how that
would then be paid for Amazon are agre
agree ageing to pay up to 30% of the
production costs is what I'm being told
and um then when Legacy does finally get
made it will show on um Paramount plus
first in the United States then the next
day it'll show on um Prime and then
it'll go on Paramount plus as well
internationally following that very
similar to the deal that they had
regarding peard Series this deal though
also include um something about the TV
movies that are being produced I don't
know if it's section 31 is included in
this but I'm assuming it is but I don't
know for certain so that's the rumor now
um no I say it's a rumor I'm I've had
this from two different sources one from
Amazon and one from Paramount so I'm
reasonably confident this is true now I
have had a couple of people come back to
me including a couple of actors from um
peard series saying that this isn't true
and that actually fake rumors are not
helpful for one I don't do fake rumors
on this channel I never have done and my
record speaks for itself I have had
several things where I've been first and
I've been accurate so that's the first
thing the second thing is I am not
saying that Legacy is in development all
I'm saying is there is agreement between
Paramount and um Prime on how this will
be funded my standing is because of the
financial situation currently at
Paramount they wanted this agreement in
place before anything else happens so
somebody like Todd stashwick who I adore
as an actor would have no insight into
this so if he comes out and says no it's
not true and I very much doubt he
watched my video and listened I think
somebody's just gone there's this rumor
what do you want to say about it and
he's obviously then said no it's not
true because he's not heard anything
anything he doesn't know anything about
it that's fine I am not saying any of
the production people would know
anything about this I am saying this is
a financial agreement between people at
Paramount I know about this because my
sources do very boring admin work in
this area so they are aware of the
agreement I think in my video I did
actually say this was signed which would
did imply that there was a
contract I have to correct that slightly
because actually to be fair I don't know
if this is has gone as far as sort of
contracted um I just know that it's all
I was actually told is there's an
agreement I also did say to you guys
that there was a um timetable for
production the idea being that this
would go into production at the end of
this year hopefully to be on screens at
the end of next year I do feel I need to
clarify that slightly as well because
that seems to be sort of a penciled in a
agreement not necessarily again
contracted and my understanding after
talking to people in this field now for
the last two three years is that these
sort of things almost never work out
that they will come with sort of like an
agreement in principle but then when
they actually start doing the boring job
of getting people actually in a studio
space that it tends to then go a bit
sideways and things get pushed forwards
or sometimes pushed backwards and you
know sometimes they happen soon than
planned and sometimes they take longer
it's dependent on people's availability
and things when you know which makes
sense to me it's once you start getting
into the Practical right how are we
doing this when are we get Studio space
blah blah blah that things happen you
know so when you get into the actual
organizing the development and writing
scripts again I'm not saying any of that
is done and I didn't in the original
video just to clarify again there is an
agreement in principle I don't know if
it's contracted but there is agreement
between Paramount secret hideout and
Prime on how a legacy series will then
be
funded I have been told again that the
Legacy project was always going to
happen there was it was never in doubt
that this was going to happen it was
just when and how were Powerman going to
pay for it at the end of the day
Paramount does have serious Financial
issues at the moment they are going
through a sale at the moment with
redstone the main sort of shareholder
deciding they want to sell the shares it
looks today like actually Sundance have
got involved in this and put a formal
bid in today that Hasen that has relased
deadline I think announced that
literally yesterday Warner Brothers is
still interested wait for Apple to get
involved that almost certainly will
happen one of the largest and most
successful in recent years studios in
the world is currently up for sale and
up for sale in a way that means
companies can actually go in and just
bid for the shares that Redstone own and
get control and interest there isn't the
complications of things like buying um
when sort of like Amazon bought Prime
and Amazon bought MGM and stuff that's
not going to be the case this is
actually a relatively easy and possibly
relatively cheap way of getting control
of a major studio and CBS oh my dog's
barking Postman must be here
so expect there to be big changes and I
did talk about that again in the video
that that might change things quite
dramatically in the next 12 months no
project is going to be potentially safe
when new owners come in I can't control
that all I can do is tell you what I'm
being told by sources that are
reliable they have reason for it and no
I'm sorry actors even people involved in
the creative side of peard Etc I have no
I I completely believe they would know
nothing about this this was again going
to be a deal that I'm absolutely certain
bosses at the top would want to keep
quite secret and I probably quite
annoyed that I've leaked it but again I
can't control that that's not my problem
I will tell you guys what I'm told I
will always put my hand on my heart and
swear on my kids' lives that it's honest
and true I can't control if things then
change but I will try to keep you as
involved as I possibly can and informed
as best as I possibly can about the
franchises that I really care about like
Star Trek and if anybody else doesn't
like that
tough if you are new to the Channel
please like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com sidre
where most of our new videos do premere
first and you get to see it without the
adverts you lucky bunnies finally you
can go to c.co where there are articles
including an article based on this topic
um about most of our videos and we try
to add a little bit more information for
you to digest go check that out too the
the Articles take me aged to write
actually so please do go check that out
as always please stay safe enjoy your
day and I'll see you next
[Music]
time